buckle up an avalanche is coming I've
been telling you about this it will
destroy if there's any remaining
credibility of the tinfoil hat
conspiracy theorists and the rage media
mob in this country along with their
allies in the Democratic hate Trump left
and those that have abused power inside
and outside of government you are about
to face the Justice that many of you
deserve we have made a promise on this
program that we will hold all of them
accountable which has been a central
focus of this show and tonight we are
making real significant progress on
multiple fronts now what's going to
happen in the days weeks ahead is this
is about a short list of what will be
made public beyond the Muller report so
much more that proves that the reporting
and the investigations that have gone on
in this show for over two years we'll
all be proven to be true all confirm
that the investigative reporting on this
show with our ensemble team that we have
been accurate and correct all along all
while the media mob and the Democratic
Mob have lied to you repeatedly for two
and a half years this is just a short
list of what will soon be made public
for example we'll get into this tonight
the Judicial Watch they're released
today
oh it's blockbuster where do you hear we
have criminal referrals this week by
Devin Nunez Attorney General bar today
pledging an investigation this has been
long overdue the Horowitz report on FISA
abuse uber report on the issue of
leaking classified information other
information and of course the release of
more closed-door testimony
thanks to congressman Collins we have
more of that tonight we will be sharing
as a matter of fact very blockbuster
there also FISA applications gang of
eight materials no those 302s they're
all coming out and also the Ukraine
issue which is surfacing that is so much
evidence that goes right to the doorstep
of yet Joe Biden this will all come
cascading down on all these bad actors
and drown all of
those people that have abused their
power let's start with Capitol Hill
Attorney General Bill Barr today
testifying before the House
Appropriations Committee and he was
there to talk about the DOJ his budget
but the conversation soon turned to the
Muller report and faced with the
undeniable fact that Trump Russia
collusion was a giant hoax
we had the FBI nine-month investigation
the house Intel investigation bipartisan
Senate investigation and the words are
clear the Muller investigation every
single one of these investigations yeah
say there was no Russia collusion
whatsoever none and they all in the
media mob got it wrong and now they're
shifting to new conspiracy theories we
want Donald Trump's taxes oh maybe the
Attorney General is covering up major
phantom crimes hidden deep within the
special councils full report and
president obstructed justice even though
the Attorney General and deputy it's
early General said no it did not happen
and by the way you can watch Rachel
Maddow the leader of this tin foil hat
conspiracy Brigade once again they're
there hoping and hyping and lying to
their viewers with a pack of twisted
lies Washington Post New York Times not
much different once again pushing
articles based on hearsay from anonymous
sources the left demanding that the full
report be released immediately but the
Attorney General today testifying that
the full report will be released within
a week no requests for executive
privilege by the president have been
made and the only word actions were
applied based on strict legal guidelines
you know like not giving away sources
and methods you're not allowed to leak
or give out grand jury information
that's against the law
what's this now in my letter of the -
March 29th identified four areas that I
feel should be redacted and I think most
people would agree the first is grand
jury information 6e material the second
is information that the ice the
intelligence community believes would
reveal intelligence sources and methods
the third are information in the report
that could interfere with ongoing
prosecution's and finally
we intend to redact information that
implicates the privacy or reputational
interests of peripheral players where
there is decision not to charge them
from my standpoint by the by within a
week I will be in a position to release
the port to the public well we already
know there was no collusion there was no
obstruction and president Trump has
nothing to hide the same cannot be said
for the high ranking FBI DOJ officials
just the upper echelon responsible for
the witch-hunt against the Trump
campaign remember code name crossfire
hurricane not the innocuous midterm
report today major news the Attorney
General bar vowing to hold them
accountable this is key and what the
Hills John Solomon is calling quote the
single sentence Russia bombshell that
bar delivered to Congress today that
very few in the media picked up on but
this is crucial take a look the office
of the inspector general has a pending
investigation of the FISA process in in
the Russian investigation and I expect
that that will be complete in probably
in May or June I am told more generally
I am reviewing the conduct of the
investigation and trying to get my arms
around all the aspects of the
counterintelligence investigation that
was conducted during the summer of 2016
now reports tonight bar will form a team
to review the FBI's actions during the
so-called phony collusion probe the
pendulum is swinging the boomerang is
now headed right back at the top deep
state actors they will all be held
accountable mark my words criminal
indictments are coming and as we have
reported congressman Devin Nunez is
preparing criminal referrals as we speak
for this very week freedom caucus
chairman Marc meadows saying that even
more criminal referrals are on the way
because of quote overwhelming evidence
of abuse of power at the highest levels
of the DOJ and the
di and we will be getting the inspector
general's report as the Attorney General
just mentioned and the FISA applications
against Carter page and the results of
the FISA investigation in the Senate and
at some point we'll also be getting the
report into leaks by John Hoover and
we'll also be getting the 302s that's
the transcripts between oh let's say
Bruce or Christopher Steele we'll get
those from the FBI we'll get the gang of
eight material and thanks to congressman
Doug Collins even today we will be
getting all of that closed-door
testimony those transcripts from all the
key deep state actors and as I said make
no mistake the evidence reveal will come
cascading down on those guilty of
corruption bias abuse of power and I
promise it will drown them and today
Collins in fact the congressman from
Georgia released testimony from James
Baker remember he was Jim Comey's number
one lawyer he was the general counsel at
the FBI when Comey was the director and
his remarks on Capitol Hill that were
just revealed today behind closed door
testimony
it literally reveals the extreme bias
abuse of power that took place that
we've been telling you about at the
highest levels of our government now
look at this look at his remarks James
Baker was quite worried pro-clinton
political bias was affecting the FBI's
investigation into then candidate
Hillary Clinton thanks to John Solomon
we also know and I expect we will have
confirmed tomorrow that Baker later
testified in a different closed-door
hearing Hillary Clinton's misconduct was
alarming and appalling and Baker said
this and it's key he believed the
Clintons should have been indicted with
crimes the Espionage Act all these
liberals concerned about obstruction of
justice
well there was intent when Hillary
deleted emails and acid-washed or hard
drive we have in the testimony James
Baker today the exact date that they use
bleach pit but of course was he was
talked out of it by his boss Jim Comey
and a few others and that's not all this
testimony released on Baker today is
revealing
what is rampant anti-trump bias inside
the highest levels of the FBI not
rank-and-file it's what we've been
saying all along we've been right all
along the chosen candidate Hillary
Clinton got a free pass we have a dual
system of justice no equal justice under
the law no equal application of our laws
Trump he was politically persecuted they
wanted him to lose and then they had an
insurance policy when he won and Baker
testified he was quote alarmed and
listen to this freaked out when he saw
the anti-trump text between FBI
investigators struck an FBI lawyer lisa
page remember struck was writing the
exoneration with Comey in May before
they ever did the investigation and he
was the one that interviewed Hillary
Clinton he also revealed meaning James
Baker that Hillary Clinton's bought and
paid for phony Russian dossier yeah it
played a serious role in the FBI's
investigation into Trump but we now know
Clinton paid for it they knew it then we
know it wasn't verified it wasn't
corroborated and the author
well you can't verify something he would
never stand by himself because he
doesn't stand by it so in other words
there would have been no probable cause
to investigate the campaign without
Clinton's dirty Russian dossier
but of course Baker actually read the
dossier he admits prior to the election
that came out today he had a personal
relationship with one of the attorneys
from Perkins cuy that's the law firm
that the Clinton campaign funneled the
money to so they could hire fusion gps
and op research firm to then hire of
course Christopher Steele that then used
phony uncorroborated Russian dirt to
impact an election how ironic embankment
that he was the intermediary between
Perkins cuy and the FBI Baker also in
this new information today admitting he
had contact with the reporter left
winger David corn prior to the election
about the dossier and he said corn a
left-wing activist was anxious to get
the dossier into the hands of the FBI
what does it all mean that Colby's top
lawyer the number-one lawyer at the FBI
the general counsel the FBI
under Comey James Baker knew about
rampant pro-hillary anti-trump bias
inside the FBI to impact an election to
favor one candidate over another and by
the way they did nothing to stop it even
though he believed crimes were committed
and that same attorney James Baker was
in close contact with Clinton's bought
and paid for a law firm and by the way
was being fed the dirty totally phony
dossier from multiple sources including
a member of the media desperate to stop
Trump this is the United States of
America this is not a Banana Republic
and there's more Bakker testifying in
this new testimony we just got today
that after Trump became president the
Deputy Attorney General who appointed
Robert Muller rod Rosenstein while he
was seriously discussing a plot to
remove the president under the 25th
amendment and in a separate incident
Baker alleging that rod Rosenstein
offered to wear a wire and spy on
President Trump
Baker testifying that it was a very
serious offer and that Rosenstein wasn't
joking what was revealed from today's
release it should shock the conscience
of every American to their core let me
let me put it this way they tried to
influence an election and then when it
didn't work they tried to remove a duly
elected president now this damning
evidence showing rampant abuse of power
and corruption it should be on the front
page of every newspaper in this country
it is not because the rage Trump media
mob is complicit and what is a major
cover-up of a deep state coup that
threatened the very fabric fabric of
this great Republic and now tonight
because a Judicial Watch tumf it will
join us later we are finding out even
more devastating information about how
the deep stay protected Hillary Clinton
before turning their forces against
Donald Trump this is also a huge
development just out today and we're
going to break it down for you the
Freedom of Information Act request by
Judicial Watch from 2016 well today bore
fruit it forced the release of 420
two pages of FBI documents surrounding
Platte River networks member platte
river networks
that's where Hillary the mom-and-pop
shop that had her server in a bathroom
closet remember that
well one government official was
reviewing a batch of emails on the
server row quote I can say now without
reservation that there are literally
hundreds of classified emails in this
collection 18 USC 793 violation clear of
the Espionage Act because she continues
I'm very concerned about the inadvertent
release of the State Department's
equities when this collection is
released in its entirety the potential
damage to the Foreign Relations of the
United States could be significant
pretty much admitting that foreign
actors got to hold the Hillary's emails
this is all coming out today now get
this FBI notes of an interview with an
unidentified plat rivers Network
official this took place in February of
16 it shows an email from December 11
2014
Hillary's wanting to run now for
president reading quote Hillary cover-up
operation work ticket archive cleanup
cover-up operation then they go further
they actually give the exact date that
they use the bleach pit to wipe the
server clean and the official being
interview stated that the cover-up
operation email quote probably related
to change to 60-day email retention
policy backup but we know now that just
a few months later Platte River networks
downloaded the bleach pit from a vendor
source called SourceForge at 11:42 a.m.
hang on
March 31st 2015 what was happening then
oh the Democratic candidates were
debating trying to get the nomination
Wow
perfect time to get rid of all this we
know the exact second she obstructed
justice in this case that was after the
deletions prior to the beating up of the
devices with hammers bleach pit used on
our server let's sum this up so the FBI
had proved Hillary Clinton mishandled
hundreds if not thousands Topsy
they're classified emails clear
violation of the Espionage took place
bent over backwards they didn't charge
her even page and struck admitted that
oh the Attorney General and the DOJ were
protecting her because they're all
Democrats the FBI also had proof that
Clinton decided to erase the 33,000
subpoenaed emails acid-washed the hard
drives elite spit beat up the devices
with hammers remove SIM cards and yet
they didn't even consider charging her
with obstruction
it was a rigged investigation and yet we
spent the last two years on a witch-hunt
against donald trump based on phony
campaign op research clinton putting
together a phony russian dossier and as
i said at the top of the monologue the
Avalanche is coming equal justice is
about to be served
call me clinton struck page mccabe
tick-tock